DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE."
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE IN A
RECESSION.
>> THE EVIDENCE IS STRONG WE ARE
NOT IN A RECESSIONARY PERIOD.
>> NOT CONSISTENT WITH AN
ECONOMY IN RECESSION.
>> WHY ARE WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS
TRYING TO REDEFINE RECESSION?
>> WE ARE NOT REDEFINING
RECESSION.
>> Greg: PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
PREDICTION THERE BEING NO
RECESSION LASTING ABOUT AS LONG
AS KAMALA'S DOOMED PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
DEMOCRATS ARE PUSHING MORE
MASSIVE SPENDING FOR SOME
REASON, TO GET US OUT OF IT.
BIDEN IS BRUSHING OFF THE BAD
ECONOMIC NEWS WHILE CLAIMING
DISHING OUT $700 BILLION FOR
THINGS LIKE FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THAT WILL ACTUALLY
LOWER INFLATION.
>> CHAIRMAN POWELL AND MANY OF
THE SIGNIFICANT BANKING
PERSONNEL AND ECONOMISTS SAY WE
ARE NOT IN A RECESSION.
WE CREATED 9 MILLION NEW JOBS SO
FAR AS I'VE BECOME PRESIDENT.
BUSINESSES ARE INVESTING IN
AMERICA AND RECORD RATES.
THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT WILL
ADD ANOTHER $370 BILLION IN
CLEAN ENERGY TAX CREDITS AND
RECONCILIATION.
THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A
RECESSION TO ME.
>> Greg: NOW THAT BIDEN'S
PREDICTION HAS FLOPPED,
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA ARE
GETTING ON THE SAME PAGE TO TRY
TO CONVINCE AMERICANS THINGS
AREN'T THAT BAD.
>> WE HAVE TO REMEMBER WHAT
TIMES WE ARE LIVING IN.
IT'S HAPPENING EVERYWHERE.
>> WE ARE IN A TRANSITION.
>> WE ARE TRANSITIONING CLEARLY.
>> TRANSITION AND WE ARE SEEING
SLOWING AS WE WOULD HAVE
EXPECTED.
>> THE RECESSION, THE WORLD I
THINK IS A POLITICAL FOOTBALL.
>> WHETHER YOU AGREE OR YOU
DON'T, STUFF IS GETTING DONE.
>> YOU DON'T THINK THIS IS AN
INDICATOR OF AN IMPENDING
RECESSION OR ONE ALREADY HERE?
>> I DON'T.
>> THIS IS THE KIND OF REACTION
THAT JEROME POWELL MIGHT WANT TO
SEE WHICH IS THINGS COOLING OFF.
>> Greg: JEEZ.
THAT WAS PAINFUL.
ROSANNA, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> Rosanna: THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO THE TABLE.
JANINE, I AM SITTING IN HER
SEAT.
NOBODY CAN FILL HER SHOES BUT
SHE'S MY SISTER FROM ANOTHER
MR. WITH A LAW DEGREE.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
IT SEEMS LIKE SPENDING GOT US
INTO THIS PLACE AND NOW THEY
THINK SPENDING CAN GET US OUT OF
IT.
>> Rosanna: I'M NOT A
WORDSMITH BUT I FEEL LIKE THESE
POLITICIANS, THEY LOVE TO PLAY
SEMANTICS WITH US.
SO HAVE WE NOT HEARD SEMANTICS
BEFORE?
SEXUAL RELATIONS?
RECESSION?
WE ARE GETTING SCREWED EITHER
WAY.
>> Greg: VERY GOOD.
>> Rosanna: DID YOU LIKE THAT?
I THINK I HAD TO BRING MY
A-GAME.
I GO SHOPPING.
I GO TO THE GROCERY STORE.
I HAVE A FAMILY.
EVERYTHING HAS GONE UP.
BUTTER, EGGS, MILK, GAS.
IS THAT TRANSITORY?
I DON'T KNOW.
HE HAS GONE ON FOR A YEAR AND
IT'S GETTING WORSE.
>> Greg: IT'S A GREAT POINT.
REPUBLICANS AND NONLIBERALS
ENGAGED IN THE REAL WORLD BY
BUILDING PRACTICAL STUFF, THE
DEMS FIGURE IF YOU JUST CHANGE
THE LANGUAGE THE PROBLEMS WILL
DISAPPEAR.
A WOMAN IS NO LONGER A WOMAN
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH
NONBINARY.
SO MANY OTHER EXAMPLES.
FOR EXAMPLE, SEXUAL RELATIONS.
CRIME.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT THEY DID
IN SOVIET RUSSIA.
THEY WOULD TELL THE POPULATION
SUCH BLATANTLY OBVIOUS LIES THAT
NO RATIONAL PERSON WOULD BELIEVE
IT.
THEY WOULD SAY UP IS DOWN.
BLACK IS WHITE.
NO BREAD LINES.
YOU'D BE STANDING THE MIDDLE OF
A BREAD LINE.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO INDEPENDENT
MEDIA OR FREEDOM OF SPEECH, THE
POPULATION REALLY COULDN'T
CHALLENGE IT.
WHEN YOU TRY TO CHALLENGE IT,
THEY WILL CRUSH YOU.
SO HE SAT THERE AND YOU TAKE THE
LIVE, YOU TAKE THE LIE AND THEN
THE LIES GET BIGGER.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT.
THEY WANT TO MAKE THE POPULATION
SUBMISSIVE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU BELIEVE
IT.
IT MATTERS IF YOU ACCEPT IT.
BECAUSE ONCE YOU EXCEPT THE
LIES, YOU -- YOU'RE BASICALLY
SAYING DO WHATEVER YOU WANT WITH
ME.
THEN THEY CAN DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT WITH YOU.
THEY CAN CONTROL THE POPULATION
THAT WAY.
WE HAVE NEVER KIND OF HAVE
BLATANT PROPAGANDA LIKE THIS IN
THIS COUNTRY BEFORE UNTIL NOW.
MEN CAN GET PREGNANT.
THE BORDERS SECURE.
THE AFGHANISTAN EVACUATION WAS
FANTASTIC.
THERE WAS NO LAPTOP.
IT WAS FAKE.
THIS IS NOT A RECESSION.
WE'VE NEVER TRIED TO DO THIS
BEFORE BUT NOW YOU CAN PULL IT
OFF BECAUSE THE PRESS AND
PROSECUTORS AND THE BIG TECH
MONOPOLIES ARE PARTICIPATING IN
THE LIE.
AND THEY'LL TELL YOU YOU ARE A
LIAR FOR CHALLENGING IT OR
THEY'LL CENSOR YOU.
THEY WILL EVEN INVESTIGATE YOU
BUT I LIKE THE NEW THING ABOUT
TRANSITION.
I THINK IT'S BRILLIANT.
GERALDO.
WE ARE NOT GETTING A DIVORCE,
HONEY.
I AM TRANSITIONING TO ANOTHER
HOUSE WHERE I WILL BE SLEEPING
WITH OTHER WOMEN.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA.
>> Geraldo: THAT IS A
TRANSITION I CANNOT ABIDE.
>> Jesse: DANA, I'M NOT
STEALING HER JEWELRY.
I AM TRANSITIONING OWNERSHIP.
COULD YOU IMAGINE A FOOTBALL
COACH GETS OUT THERE AFTER A
LOSS AND TELLS THE FANS, GUYS,
WE DIDN'T LOOSE.
WE ARE TRANSITIONING AWAY FROM
OUR WINNING STREAK INTO A MORE
STABLE PERIOD OF PLAY.
>> Greg: DO YOU KNOW WHEN I
GOT FIRED THE FIRST TIME, THE
H.R. PERSON SAID THEY WERE
TRANSITIONING ME OUT OF MY JOB.
>> Jesse: THERE IT IS.
>> Greg: I STARTED LAUGHING.
IT'S AMAZING.
I WILL NEVER FORGET THAT.
THE GUY WHO SAID THAT WHO'S
WATCHING PROBABLY.
DANA.
COULDN'T HAVE DONE A BETTER JOB
OF EXPLAINING THIS?
WHY COULDN'T THEY HAVE JUST BEEN
HONEST MAYBE AND SAID LOOK,
THESE ARE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES.
WE ARE COMING OUT OF A PANDEMIC.
INSTEAD THEY DECIDED TO PLAY
WITH THE WORDS.
>> Dana: WHY WOULDN'T YOU JUST
DO THAT, IF 75% OF THE COUNTRY.
65% OF THE COUNTRY THINK WE ARE
IN A RECESSION ALREADY.
75% OF DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT
JOE BIDEN TO RUN AGAIN.
85% OF THE COUNTRY THINGS WE ARE
ON THE WRONG TRACK.
ADDING RECESSION.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY IT WAS
SUCH A BIG DEAL BECAUSE THE
STORY THEN BECAME THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS SO WORRIED ABOUT
THE WORD RECESSION THAT THEY
WOULD DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO
TRY TO GET YOU NOT TO SAY IT.
A LOT OF MEDIA WENT ALONG WITH
IT BUT THIS IS A TECHNICAL
DEFINITION.
IMAGINE GEORGE W. BUSH OR
DONALD TRUMP TRYING TO GET AWAY
WITH IT.
THE MEDIA WOULD HAVE NEVER DONE
THAT AND THAT'S FINE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO BE HONEST ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
IT'S FOR TWITTER AND THE MEDIA.
PEOPLE AT HOME, THEY KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING, AS ROSANNA JUST HAD.
AND YOU HAVE A RESTAURANT.
I AM SURE YOU KNOW THAT
EVERYTHING HAS GONE UP AND YOU
HAVE CUSTOMERS AND YOU WANT THEM
TO KEEP COMING BACK.
>> Greg: WHEAT.
YOU HAVE A RESTAURANT?
>> Rosanna: YES.
GERALDO WAS THERE.
DANA.
A SPEAKER EVERYONE HAS GOT TO
GO.
ONE OF THE THING.
THE NEXT WORD THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO TRY TO REDEFINE IS
STAGFLATION.
YOU ARE REALLY IN THE SOUP.
THAT WILL BE THE NEXT WORD THAT
THERE HAD TO SAY, THEY WILL
POINT TO THE JOB MARKETS.
JOBS WILL STRONG.
IF YOU HAVE TO HAVE THREE JOBS,
THE JOB MARKET IS GOING TO BE
STRONG.
>> Greg: I THOUGHT STAGFLATION
WAS WHEN THE STRIPPER GETS
PREGNANT AT THE STAG PARTY.
>> Jesse: THERE YOU ARE
REDEFINING WORDS AGAIN.
>> Greg: GERALDO.
THERE IS THIS STRATEGY OF
PRODUCING A BILL THAT NOBODY CAN
POSSIBLY READ.
NOT EVEN THE MEDIA READS IT.
WE'RE GOING TO READ IT.
WE HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO READ IT.
NOBODY ALSO GOING TO READ IT.
>> Geraldo: NOBODY READS IT
BUT THE LOBBYISTS.
I'VE ABSOLUTELY NO PROBLEM.
I WELCOME ROSANNA.
WONDERFUL RESTAURANT.
YOU ARE THE BEST.
YOU AND THE JUDGE ARE LIKE
SISTERS.
>> Greg: AND YOU ARE LIKE THE
HAIRY SISTER.
>> Geraldo: I AM THE HARRY
SISTER.
CHARLES PAYNE, NEIL CAVUTO SAY
THAT IT'S A RECESSION SO I AGREE
IT'S A RECESSION.
IN TERMS OF A BILL THAT NOBODY
READS, I HAVE NO PARTICULAR
PROBLEM.
I KNOW WHY ANYONE WOULD, WITH
THE TOP 50 CORPORATIONS PAYING
15% MINIMUM TAX.
THEY PAY NO TAX.
BIDEN, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
TELLING THE TRUTH AND 50 OF THE
LARGEST CORPORATIONS DO NOT PAY
ANY FEDERAL INCOME TAX, THEN I
WANT THEM TO PAY SOME MONEY.
I STILL WANT THESE BIG
CORPORATIONS TO PAY SOMETHING
RATHER THAN BASING IN THE
BAHAMAS FOR THE CHANNEL ISLANDS
AND USING THAT AS A TAX --
>> Greg: EVERY PROBLEM TO THEM
IS THE NAIL.
THE USE THE HAMMER OF TAXES.
WHY CAN'T THEY JUST TRYING TO
SOLVE A PROBLEM WITHOUT
BURDENING PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY
CREATE THINGS.
>> Geraldo: ISN'T THAT A
PROBLEM THAT THE 50 TOP
PROFITABLE CORPORATIONS PAY NO
TAXES QUESTIONING >> Dana: NO.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
TRUE.
THE WAY CONGRESS HAS SET THE
TAX.
NOBODY'S SAYING CORPORATIONS ARE
DOING SOMETHING ILLEGAL.
THEY ARE FOLLOWING THE TAX CODE
BUT THE CONGRESS CAN'T SEE TO
LEGISLATE ANYTHING.
THEY SAY LET US AT ATTACKS.
ONE OF THE GOING TO GET FOR THAT
ADDITIONAL MONEY?
>> Geraldo: AMONG OTHER THINGS
THEY CLAIM THAT OVER
$300 BILLION WILL BE TAKEN OFF
THE DEFICIT.
THAT BENEFITS THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN.
RATHER THESE CORPORATIONS
GETTING ALL THIS PROFIT AND
DISTRIBUTE IN IT AS DIVIDENDS
WHICH ONLY HELPS THEIR
FAT CAT --
>> Dana: WE'LL SEE.
ALMOST ALL OF THEM ARE ON RECORD